On a dark evening, when you look up at the stars, you might see
the glowing band of light we call the Milky Way.
This region of the sky is so dense with interstellar
dust and stars,
it blocks our view of a huge portion of our own galaxy.
We know in general the shape of the place
we live -- but the details have been obscured.
Until now.
Researchers have finally been able to sneak
a peek at the parts of the sprawling spiral
arms that lie behind the core of the Milky
Way galaxy.
Unlike visible light, microwaves can pass
through these cosmic obstructions.
Using the Very Long Baseline Array of radio
telescopes,
scientists found a peculiar microwave source on the other side of the galaxy.
The source was found in a region of the galaxy
where stars are actively being formed.
By measuring positional shifts in these microwaves
against the stable background of distant quasar galaxies,
researchers discovered that this
distant microwave source
lies 20.4 kiloparsecs away.
(about 66,000 lightyears)
following the spiral from the source to the center of the galaxy
shows that this microwave source
is part of the Scutum–Centaurus Arm of the Milky Way,
While we might not be able to see what’s
behind the galactic center with optical telescopes,
measurements like these can eventually help
us to fully map out the Milky Way Galaxy.
And with better maps, our galactic selfies
may become more accurate,
even if the Delta quadrant is still a little fuzzy.